what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alva here and I'm John Paul John Paul
and I you know a lot a lot a lot of
people have saddened to talk about this
video oh your reaction to it and talked
about it
I know it's about Logan Paul yeah I
don't know Logan Paul honestly that well
I just like nothing I don't mean in
person cuz I mean here's what I know
about Logan Paul everyone hates him and
he's also one of the most famous
youtubers almost a hundred percent of my
association with both Logan and Jake
Paul is that they're they're very famous
and most people hate and apparently Jake
Paul put out a really awful Christmas
album that's all I've heard and Logan
Paul did some video he took down
apparently we have it I have no idea
other than the warning signs no taking
it contains suicide and death which
sounds horrible yeah and number one on
trending was his apology for putting up
the video oh boy
and somehow this video got on trending -
oh I've seen is the headline of this of
this video in fact the way I found out
about this was was because double
toasted did a video on it so all I know
is the major caption of Logan Paul finds
something in the woods and that's all I
know about this so this right now
especially knowing that there's
controversy and that his apology is
dragging I'm like I don't know what
angle this is coming from and what is
about to happen here because I've never
watched David's video let's check it out
we'll watch it and we'll see what this
is all about camera cuts every 12
minutes so we'll have to cut it know at
some point as the videos 14 minutes long
kind of nervous to watch I have to I'm
pretty nervous I'm like word is gonna
like ruin my mood for the rest of the
day
[Music]
this is so artificial I can't stand it
it's so artificial ah happy requisite
[Music]
I I know he probably means some of these
things that's the most disingenuous
thing I've seen very long
dude I kind of gross all right before I
go into any opinions on the video which
I think are pretty clear by now loved it
top five trending well I I like I said
earlier don't really know Logan Paul I
don't and the other thing is too is I
haven't heard actual responses to this
video all I've heard is that this video
has caused a lot of controversy Logan
Paul took it down and there been people
do in response videos to it and then I
saw Logan Paul do an apology but I
haven't seen the apology video either
that's all I know so I don't know the
details as to what is causing an uproar
exactly so all I can give you is my
honest feedback on this experience of
watching the blog itself it is an
incredibly disrespectful video yes I
mean he has this opening acting like
he's gonna you know he clearly shot it
after he got back from Japan and he or
maybe he's in this age I don't know what
it doesn't matter he's due tonight after
this experience yeah went down and he's
talking to the camera like hey I'm gonna
show you guys something this is gonna be
a message field it's before it's gonna
be a message filled video and then he
hops into the vlog and it's it's so
goofy and I'm like okay I understand if
you're doing a vlog and you're joking
around cuz that's your thing you're a
vlogger you got the YouTube personality
totally get that at the same time though
he's listing these facts about the
forest that I've heard before I didn't
realize it was a hundred deaths 100
suicides approximated a year but if
you're talking about there's a hundred
suicides a year and there's 352 days in
a year of course there's gonna be
there's a third of a chance to see a
dead body in a forest is like one third
of a chance SOTA Ridge there's got to be
a couple yeah even just so before even
going into the forest and then doing a
like trying to make a fun vlog about
maybe we'll see a haunting or maybe
we'll see ghosts is that's [ __ ] up
that's just that's flat-out [ __ ] up
because this is a place where real
people go
and I about a hundred people a year that
you're telling the audience right up
front and center and then you're going
in there trying to make some funny joke
vlog about it with absolutely no respect
for your brother than on through the
countless people that have died in this
forest
countless people and I mean this is a
yearly thing yeah and it's not like
nobody's ever filmed there or whatever
but at the same time it's like you look
at any like paranormal show or whatever
at least there's an effort of any kind
to at least handle with care and until
the moment happens and you know
intermittently throughout the rest of
the video they just don't like he's the
video starts with him doing his like
who's on first thing with fiji water in
the mount fuji already making us all
look bad and then and then yeah I'd like
I get that you respond stuff with humor
or whatever but it didn't seem like he
ever took the situation that's reality I
felt like he was very much aware this
was still a vlog and he was still trying
to be entertaining for the camera I'm
like dude dial it down now is the time
for some sincerity
hey I just hated his personality before
all that yeah before that I was like oh
you're one of those YouTube
personalities with the super artificial
like I'm vlogger do you know who was
having fun and when you try to get
sincere at any point it seems a smart
official completely yes completely
artificial I hated it and then you've
got this music coming in and out like to
really guide your emotions through
certain things and like I it's what I
don't understand too is this video is
edited it's like do you so I don't
assembled someone assembled in fact
after you find the dead body you know
you could have edited out a lot of the
jokes you could have edit out a lot of
the humor and he says stupid [ __ ] like
wrong day to wear the hat it's like
takes like the hat off that you're in
the forest he'll take it off like take a
moment to be sincere like be more aware
of yourself I get it if you go into
shock
you just found a dead body I've had
death in my life I've seen my I've seen
dead boy I've seen dead bodies I found I
saw my dad's dead body the day he died
and I had know plenty of people who have
lost people the suicide so this whole
and I'm sure he knows something he's
must have meant at least got someone or
encountered or heard it's it's kind of
shocking how how out of tune he was his
friend seemed incredibly more real yeah
appropriate
yeah Ponce's even approaching
appropriate spots uncomfortable laughter
is understandable to me having this hunk
but the way he was doing it seemed like
no I'm making a vlog now I make I'm
making a video still and and there's
like even him going all jokes aside with
the football signs and then kicking it
oh he's full of [ __ ] the guy's full of
[ __ ] every couple minutes he'll
basically say like I'm not gonna do this
thing I do I do the subscribe button I
don't think so I'm like you don't want
to do it him saying that right then and
there is him saying the subscriber and
then he goes ahead and says subscribe
yeah and a video like this just makes me
sit here feeling like it really comes
across as though you grew up in some
kind of bubble where you get to be your
own queen bee and and you get to behave
kind of like nothing is real ever and
that really takes away like Sean Penn
from Fast Times at Ridgemont High it
doesn't mean just the kind of entitled
millennial version of that yeah he's
kind of to me at least based off this
video he sort of represents the worst of
your of your stereotypical millennial
yeah because so much gets in the wit
like whenever they try to skirt or to
flirt with the topic suicide and that
I've never we've all at some point done
one of those like seek help it's okay
what you feel it like and it to a degree
like yeah that sentiment is everywhere
and we all get it I've never seen it as
disingenuous now appears now over there
like we're here for you because it's a
and then oh hey here's me that we got to
say the genuine line and then let's go
back to funny joke I'm like dude there's
no room for that there's no room for
that right from here on out you
shouldn't have started off the vlog that
way to begin with then after you
actually see a physical dead body from
someone who killed themselves there
should be no more jokes like don't think
less of it like if you don't
don't put up a vlog here like don't ya
we're literally editing what kinda later
yeah what's the point of this cut out
the jokes like if you're gonna edit
because I get it that sometimes
sometimes things can be misread from a
cameras perspective or whatever from a
third-person perspective as opposed to
actually being there but that's the time
where you're supposed to be really
genuine and get in touch with reality
like yeah I don't care if he made a
disclaimer that you know resorting to
humors your way to deal with
uncomfortableness or what or whatever
the hell you said that's it just doesn't
look like he's taking a situation fully
seriously now it seemed like he was even
made a joke about this videos game to
monetize anyway I felt like he was
really still aware that he's making a
video yeah she's trying to be
entertaining so maybe there's that
crossroads path the same time I'm like I
saw the way this guy was behaving before
they got to the forest yeah he just
seems like he seems like a dick this is
my real introduction on one hand part of
me believes that he believes that he is
being sincere like I'm this kind of
seems like the way he expresses and if
that's the case I'm like you you you
have to change some things cuz yeah it's
like I understand that that vlogs part
of it is things start out one way and
end up another and if the videos started
out wacky and then they got serious when
the actual moment came that would be one
thing but even the way they introduced
this video is a bit confusing because
it's like oh we got more than we
bargained for nothing you've ever seen
before you know and I'm like is this why
are you building this like a big moment
for your channel yeah exactly that's
it's a big moment for me you chose yeah
when I'm like you're saying in the video
that they made horror movies about it
they've done all this you you're doing
nothing new but being insulting you're a
vlogger who's wandered into you know a
fragile place you know like a bull in a
china shop and and you just kind of
behave that way throughout the entire
video and and everything this video
tries to do fails because it's like the
only thing that succeeds in all this is
he looks terrible because he comes out
of the woods and immediately starts like
schmoozing
folks and making jokes out of this
situation like over there
and I'm like yeah don't go over there
act like you just saw what you keep
saying
yeah saw like yeah yeah this was gross
man this is this is disheartening man
you know i-i've never what check I've
never checked out Logan Paul videos
before I've never like gone out of my
way to see you Logan Paul video and all
I think is I like we said before we
watch this video I ever heard is people
hate this guy yeah yeah he's super
famous you know and what I'm sure part
of I'm sure there's a certain amount of
people who watch because of that yeah
because bad behavior is fun too is
entertainment value we have reality
shows based all over that so I'm not
surprised that he gets such huge I think
it seemed like he was putting up this
video not for a message of awareness
about suicide it seemed like it was
about a movement in a wave like just
because it D monetized it doesn't mean
that you're not gonna get promotion
video views and attention for it and
subscribers like I'm sure that's what
that was his main intent was like this
is gonna be a big video because we got
something wrong camera this doesn't seem
compassionate toward people who struggle
with suicide people who have been
affected by suicide it doesn't feel
compassionate to those people at all it
feels any part of the video that talks
about that directly feels like kind of
an obligatory this is what we say now
yeah yeah I hate this I am very morbidly
curious to see what the apology looks
like yeah alright guys well I'm ending
the video bye